toggy's still around taki will taki has
to be summoned
for tagi to make an appearance
matagi can exist in emote form thank you
tasmanian si puma
okay let's play 3-0 okay much quicker in
getting a game
so okay i'm muting alerts and i was
bribed to play the wayward queen attack
i'm not gonna pre-move this because
g6 is legal okay
so this is my my dubious
i don't know why i'm playing this but
and it's probably playable
like why not d3
i might have to just move back all the
way
if i move like h3 there's knight d4
which is unpleasant
um it's already kind of unpleasant
maybe bishop's e5
it's playable though yeah i'll treat
this as a
like kind of king's indian
[Music]
king's indian with a bishop on g5 yeah
so i'll take and
play bishop g2 that's not too bad
pressure against d5
i'm kind of hoping black plays d4 and
then it's just kind of a nice
easy development for white
that move okay if i take here there's
takes and then
uh i can't take on c5 because this or
this
i take with bishop or maybe even pawn
stick with pawn off for the queen trade
25 92 defending the knight castle
um probably get the queen off the d file
um what to do a3
just trying to play quick down a little
bit of time
uh play this move yeah i'll address the
subs and cheers and everything after the
game
will be the appropriate thing to do
um that's actually a really good move
oh i have c4
i want to play e5 soon shut out the
i'm trying to shut out both bishops
yeah this gives me just enough time to
exceed some initiative
and the light wants to return to c3
eventually i want to fight for the d
file
considering this but it's no good
so black might play this move
and then rook f2 bishop b7 knight c3
considering this first there's a small
trap
regulating this rook d2 b4 queen d8
not really a trap though queen c3
maybe queen c3
offering the trade
okay now i fight for the d file
really i play this move to try and
prevent black from doubling up
ah that's kind of annoying
uh there's b3 i guess
a5a4
interesting
i take
i guess i should take this way
let's do this let's move
g4 is risky but i want to give my knight
a square knight was really clumsy on e2
wow fancy
still down time
interesting let's play this move
so i over defend the pawn i want to
double up
put the queen on a happier place four
attackers
four defenders
this pawn's a bit tender
um yeah let's maneuver the knight to
an even better square
trying to calculate this line where i
get the queen
queen and pawn for two rooks oh
okay this should be good for me now
um
[Music]
it's slightly more pleasant but maybe
it's just equal
don't want things to close down
c5 is hanging currently
that's a good move
i don't know what to do
as a mouse slip a good mouse slip
no my thing
no
oh my thing oh i got skewered
that's a good game though and
i was a little bit slower that game
managed to get a winning position and i
got secured in the end
opponent played very clutchly
very clutch watch being an adverb
yeah this was a clutch move
to do that was my first stream
game in like five five days
or seven days i don't know
um well the opening
yeah i feel like this is even worse
against sicilian
because after e6 like the queen serves
no purpose
pawns defended knight's coming here what
does stockfish think
that's not too bad you've improved my
chest dramatically
i guess the queen just has to go back
and then